okay what's up
guys oh man I'm uh scrolling through
here and looking at the comments we were
going to start this at like 11:00 a.m.
but you know what I was like whatever
it's like 8:00 in the morning right now
it's 8:45 almost 9:00 so I'm going to
call this comics and coffee because like
eons ago me and Benny were toying around
with the idea of creating something
called comics and coffee that was going
to be our initial um our initial premise
here is we were going to talk about
comics in the morning with coffee
although I don't know if that's if that
was ever going to like turn into
anything but it is now so this might be
like a Sunday routine where like every
Sunday morning like we talk about comics
and coffee I don't know but um I've
actually I've actually not got coffee
I've actually got tea instead but you
know it's all good and my neighbors are
waking
up but um
but this tea is not very
good this tea sucks this is a liptin tea
the brisk they call it hold on I I'll
set see if you guys can see this or not
they call it lip in the
brisk I'll call it LIF in the [__]
because it tastes like [__] it tastes
awful not that I really know what [__]
tastes like I don't know in any event I
never understood that phrase like why
people say like this tastes like [__]
like how do you know what what poop
tastes like like have you tasted it did
you say like I wonder what poop tastes
like and then like you decided to taste
it I mean I don't I don't know just one
of those weird things I
guess watch that taste out of my mouth
okay I've actually got to get some more
eaget juice um because I'm running low
and and here's like those of you guys
who Vape This is a shattering experience
literally I broke the tank on my um my
Nautilus or my Atlantis my Aspire
Atlantis and so this is a Teflon I
wrapped it with Teflon tape and uh just
temporary measure you know just
temporary measure and
um it's uh I ended up having to go back
and I'm GNA have to go back and and get
a new one which sucks because they're
like 40 bucks or something like that but
anyway so for those of you guys who are
going to like you know start trickling
in here in the next little bit those of
you guys who are going to be joining us
I don't think we're going to get a whole
lot of people because it's 9 o'clock in
the morning on the East Coast which
means like 6 o'clock in the morning if
you're up for some reason on the west
coast you might be seeing this but um
you are addicted to caffeine I recommend
kicking the habit and picking up
something much more mild like Crystal
weed it's a fantastic suggestion
marijuana the cured all the world's
problems but um anyway so um I don't oh
yeah yeah I don't think we're going to
get that many people showing up to this
thing but we'll see we'll see who turns
out we'll see how many people actually
show up but for those of you guys who
are going to be trickling in here um or
meth meth is I guess a good alternative
I could be like Walter White like
Heisenberg the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle that's what that's based off
of but um those of you guys who are
starting to trigger L earlier in the
chat people were um were were having
like this big debate at least we were
having like this big discussion and we
were talking about
um me pieces of [__] for breakfast we
were talking about uh Omega Level
characters like what what are Omega
Level characters things like that but
before we get into all that all right
you guys may noticed from the title Age
of Apocalypse and infinity War the
question is the question I've been
getting non-stop Rob are you going to
finish Infinity War Rob are you going to
finish Age of Apocalypse Infinity War
yes we will finish that at some point
along the line keep in mind Infinity war
is not really relevant to anything going
on in comics at all at any point in time
in the comic continuity right now it
doesn't matter even the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has nothing to do with infinity
War they're calling it Infinity War but
it's The Infinity Gauntlet explained
basically it's or not really Infinity
Gauntlet explain but it's The Infinity
Gauntlet event that's going on right now
so it doesn't really matter all that
much but um nonetheless you know we'll
finish that at some future point in time
Age of Apocalypse is a lot more
important and the reason why Age of
Apocalypse is more important is because
Age of Apocalypse is going to be part of
Secret Wars now I'm having I'm uploading
a video later on today about Secret Wars
2015 that is to say all the information
that I've been able to gain about Secret
Wars 2015 now again a lot of this has
come from like marvel.com but I've left
out everything this conjecture
everything that we're just kind of not
sure of I've cut all that stuff out so
there's only like five or six different
things that we know for sure and I
figured I put that in a video upload it
so you guys can be pred but it also
would really give us like this cool kind
of uh like template I guess to follow
but I want to do the same thing with
convergence I want to do the same thing
and do this setup where it's like here's
what you should be reading to get ready
for convergence which is basically DC's
not really like reboot so to speak I
guess it kind of is but it kind of isn't
like it's it's weird the way they're
doing it but
nonetheless it's uh Marvel and DC pretty
much have the same idea when it comes to
uh to rebooting the continuity so in any
event you know convergence is going to
have a lot of elor stories so like
Superman red Sun stuff like that or I
guess Red Son red I don't know anyway
when Superman it's a story about what
would happen if Superman were found by
the Russians or if he landed in Russia
instead of America so nonetheless um so
yeah so Age of Apocalypse we're going to
do that for Secret Wars um we're
probably going to have to do that
relatively soon but um nonetheless so
what I wanted to do in this video is is
again like we're you know in this live
stream we're just going to be talking
about like like comics and stuff
so that's really it um you know I just I
thought it'd be kind of fun to just kind
of talk about comics and and answer
questions you know that you guys have
about comic books in general you know
things that that might Intrigue you guys
or things you guys might find um
relatively interesting but nonetheless
so I guess um let the
questions begin at some
point oh yeah so anyway so um Omega
Level characters all right so Omega
Level characters are characters who are
like Elementals like ican for example is
considered Omega Level because he's a
fundamental part of the Earth's
ecosystem he can change the ecosystem
what one thing to keep in mind guys heat
or I'm sorry cold is simply the absence
of heat so it's not like Iceman is
creating cold he simply St like
stripping the heat away from something
is what he's doing he's taking the heat
out of anything technically speaking he
could freeze the whole earth over by
freezing the core of a planet I mean
it's entirely possible for him to do
that because of his abilities so that's
not that far out of the question but um
what's going on David
hey but uh but no that's that's what
that's what makes him an Omega Level
character um the other definitions of
Omega Level characters are pretty
straightforward these are people who are
ridiculous in their nature like people
who have reality warping abilities
people who are Immortal for example they
can't die you know these are the kind of
things that um basically implode all the
story
lines that can restart their books at
number one or again since only super
nerds by uncanny far
clowns
um you guys crack me up you guys are
pretty hard
but uh people who are Immortal people
who have reality whopping powers
different things like that like that
pretty much defines like Omega Level
characters people who have abilities
that transcend anything else that some
of the most prominent characters are
capable of like Gan gray with the
Phoenix force is Omega Level Gan gray
without the Phoenix force is just a
super powerful telepath and uh kind of a
powerful telekinetic they've done weird
things with her telekinetic Powers over
the years but um her telepathy is is
virtually unrivaled I mean it exceeds
even Charles Xavier like she's right up
there I think she might even be above
Emma Frost on her levels but um
nonetheless um can we get the Infinity
War series finished um but yeah so um
all right so so who is that horse-faced
Thor guy okay the um yes um Vulcan is an
Omega Level mutant he is the most
powerful of all three Summers brothers
but he's powerful because he can
manipulate all forms of energy like all
kinds of different energies you can
manipulate the beams of Cyclops and
here's actually kind of a fun fact um
when Vulcan was introduced to Marvel
Comics he was
introduced oh God I cannot remember the
name of the story it wasn't e is for
extinction because that was Grant
Morrison's run of the X-Men that's when
Cassandra Nova wiped out all the mutants
um in uh in
josha oh
god um I want to say it's Genesis
something or I can't remember somebody
in the chat remind me of of what that is
but Vulcan shows up and basically what
Charles Xavier says is well vulcan's
like Vulcan had like he was one of the
really really old versions of of the
X-Men like he showed up after you guys
got captured after the original X-Men
got captured and he was one of the
people I sent to rescue you that's how
Marvel introduced him in and they said
Well he kind of merged with Darwin and
then he went out into space and then
eventually he uh becomes I guess he
takes over the shiar Empire and that
leads into the war of Kings between the
Inhumans and the shiar and so on and so
forth you know it goes on and on and on
but nonetheless um yeah Vulcan is is a
super powerful mutant he can it's really
cool some of the stuff he can do I would
say you guys should look him up if you
guys don't uh if you guys don't know who
he
is all right
um what is it oh damn there's plastic on
there am I bleeding or
something I'm not bleeding because I
shaved a little bit but I've got blood
on my finger I don't know where that
blood came from oh well
anyway deadly Genesis that's what it is
thank you thank you thank you uh yes the
Scarlet Witch is an Omega Level mutant
because she can manipulate reality she
is super
powerful okay
um yeah during the tridal of Jee gray
genan gray was super super powerful okay
so um all right so so let's get let's
get to the questions
um all right let's see let's scroll back
up a little bit uh who is the horseface
Thor guy okay that is BET Ray Bill Beta
Ray Bill is a member of a race called
the corbon nightes and what actually
happened in God it was a big deal four
issue number 200 something I think I
can't remember what the exact issue is
which is weird I should be able to
remember that but um B Ray Bill shows up
he meets Thor for the first time but the
problem here is that uh Odin
accidentally confuses bet rill with Thor
which is kind of weird because you would
think Odin would know what Thor looks
like but apparently he doesn't and so he
takes Thor or takes bet Ray Bill back to
Asgard and there's some great big huge
conflict and so basically what happens
is BET Ray Bill and Thor fight each
other and B Ray Bill picks up Thor's
hammer and it I guess he kind of does
that beforehand he picks it up and
starts wielding it wordss like Nick Fury
and those guys and then Odin is like hey
you like come with me you know and that
kind of thing but nonetheless um Beta
Ray Bill was the first person to ever
demonstrate the ability to wield Thor's
hammer like that was a big deal when bet
Ray Bill first showed up and ultimately
um another Hammer was made for him
called Stormbreaker which that was one
of the reasons why a lot of people when
they saw Guardians of the Galaxy there
was that cube with the guy and looked
like he had a red cape and people
thought they saw a hammer in the bottom
corner people were like oh my God it's a
Carbonite that's Beta Ray Bill and
people were freaking out thinking that
bet Ray Bill was coming to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which would be
freaking amazing if that happened
um who do I think will be Marvel
Spider-Man man I don't know like I mean
there's so many potential actors out
there that could play the role of Peter
Parker in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I mean Marvel said they're not going to
use any other version of of Peter Parker
now here's the
question is that version of Peter Parker
going to be
interchangeable that is to say is is
Peter Parker as he appears on the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is that going to be
the same Peter Parker that we're going
to see in the Sony films that's the
question I have is he going to go back
and forth um I imagine so because it'd
be confusing to fans on both ends if you
see Peter Parker you see Spider-Man
who's in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but he's played by a totally different
person from the person who's going to be
in the Sony films that's kind of weird
especially when people know that Kevin
fagy and Amy Pascal are working together
in order to bring um I guess to reboot
the Spider-Man series on under Sony so
it's going to be kind of strange how
would you feel if uh JJ Abrams rebooted
Star Wars like he did with Star Trek I
mean no original but pre-sequels either
no original but no pre-sequels no
prequels either okay so you're talking
about if like he did with Star Trek
where like he made an alternate timeline
and everything branched off from there
um he's not going to do that as far as I
know they're going to be unique stories
like stories that we haven't seen before
with episodes I guess episodes seven
eight and n and however many others they
make going forward from there but um you
I don't know I mean I don't see JJ
Abrams doing that but again that's one
of the big reasons why there was so much
backlash about uh about getting rid of
the expanded universe because a majority
of the expanded universe stories took
place after episode 6 those took place
in the expanded universe air to the
Empire and stuff like that you know
those all picked up yuzon vong and so on
and so forth those were things that came
out of everything after episode 6 and so
Disney making their own movies after
episode 6 basically said none of that
stuff is official and and here's the
deal and I saw a few questions here and
there a few people who were asking here
in there for those of you guys who were
curious when it comes to the Disney Star
Wars films anything that's not part of
the original six films or the um the
Clone Wars cartoon series is not
official it's just Fanfare basically
it's just fanfiction stuff which again
made a lot of uh Star Wars fans upset
they were pretty pissed uh do you think
Secret Wars is made
for is made for make the history of
Heroes like the histories of the M MCU
oh do you think do I think that secret
Wars is going
to I think I understand what your
question is are you asking me if they're
going to take the secret Wars stories
and they're going to use those to make
the histories of the characters like the
histories in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe let me know if that's what
you're asking because if it is then uh
then I I'll try to I'll try to answer
better can you explain how characters
can be in different Comics at the same
time while in an event or particular
storyline in their own series that's
Marvel continuity problems that's all
that is that Marvel Marvel continuity
just doesn't make any sense those are
the pro that's the problem with Marvel
continuity is that that's why I'm glad
they're getting rid of like all these
alternate realities and they're just
kind of slimming everything down um and
we'll explain that like with with the
whole Secret Wars thing um but that's
one of the big criticisms is Marvel's
just kind of like well you know
like yes Spider-Man is fighting in the
spiderverse but you know he's also doing
other stuff
too that was one of the big one of the
big confusions that people have
um uh Captain America actually did wield
Thor's
hammer
um what do I think about Aquaman uh yes
I'm on Facebook um it's still Marvel
explained I can't update the Earl the
URL so that's you'll find that um oh god
there were a lot of questions that I
didn't
catch
um all right let's we got to scroll back
the questions are coming in so fast now
um what do I think about the what do I
think the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Civil War will be like um I think it'll
be pretty straightforward I think the
Marvel Cinematic Universe version of
Civil War will basically be if it's
going to be confined to a single film
it'll just be like hey guys here's like
a big argument we're basically have it
and they're going to pick sides again I
don't think that's going to be the case
I think Captain America 3 Civil War is
going to set the stage for later things
that being said Marvel's going to have
to beef up their lineup quite a bit
they're going to have to make things
pretty big like they're going to have to
add a lot more heroes in order to make
Civil War matter not even just because
of the comic books but because of just
the scale of what Civil War would have
to be I mean in all honesty you couldn't
call a film Captain America 3 Civil War
and then just have like Thor and iron IR
man and the Incredible Hulk versus
Captain America and Black Widow and
Hawkeye and Doctor Strange like you
couldn't do that like that would just be
stupid but what might also happen is
they might say the Captain America 3
Civil War is basically like what's left
of Hydra versus what's left of shield
and then the superheroes taking sides I
don't know it could be something like
that we have no idea so what's going on
uh
livon Zero from Singapore awesome all
right let's scroll down a little bit
more I want Mysterio in the Spider-Man
film I me that'd be kind of cool I think
Mysterio's best role was in Old Man
Logan he had tricked Wolverine into
killing all the X-Men that was
cool
uh you're clearly a mutant with the
ability to randomly produce
blood oh
yeah yes I am yes I am um what do I
think about Aquaman
um I mean I like Aquaman Aquaman's not a
terrible character I think he got a bad
rap over the years because a lot of
people were like
well Aquaman can basically talk to
fish and that was that's pretty much
what they what people said and that was
one element of his character sure but I
mean you can't Encompass the entire
Legacy of a single character by one
aspect of them like like Iron Man or not
Iron Man Aquaman has a pretty in-depth
history when it comes to DC Comics he's
pretty huge in DC Comics he has a CT
following I think and he's he's pretty
well known um what I think they're going
to do with Aquaman in this DC Universe
is that because on the poster it said
unite the seven and so I think he's
going to be the Catalyst that's going to
bring the Justice League together which
is basically going to give like Credence
to Aquaman it's going to give him more
respect I think in the eyes of the
mainstream which I think he's long
overdue for
that uh let's
see can you explain how oh yeah we
already did
that um am I looking forward to the
Black Panther movie oh yeah like the
Black Panther movie is going to be
pretty awesome um I think it's high time
that we saw a black panther film the
question I have though and this is going
to be kind of the downside is what are
they going to do with him now I mean
Chad Bossman as far as I understand or I
don't know if it's Boseman or or
whatever his name is I think he'd be a
pretty good black panther but the issue
here
is what are you going to do with this
character I mean he was supposed to be
the middleman in Civil War he was
supposed to be the one that played the
role of Spider-Man now he's
not so what are they going to do with
him you know I imagine all these ideas
they had I imagine when Marvel sat down
and said all right let's throw Black
Panther in the middle of Civil War let's
give him the place of Spider-Man that
they basically said like this is
tentative like this is just what if we
don't get Spider-Man and so I'm pretty
sure them getting Spider-Man was the
main thing black panther was the backup
and then they had other ideas of what
they were going to do with black panther
if the Civil War deal actually came
through which it did so I'm I'm I don't
know I'm kind of curious to see what
happens
um who would you prefer The Runaways of
the Young Avengers uh to be in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe um honestly I
don't care for each one I don't care for
either one to be honest um I never
really care that much about The Runaways
or the Young Avengers I mean even during
Civil War like we skipped over The
Runaways because they just weren't
important it was they were off in like
San Francisco or something like that and
they were just like hey here's some
stuff like Civil Wars going on yes and
we're just trying to stay out of it
whatever I didn't think they were too
too relevant um the Young Avengers were
cool to a degree because you had like
hulkling which was who was a shape
shifter um I think them introducing a
shape shifter to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe could be cool but I think a lot
of people would look at hulkling because
he's so much more obscure than mystique
and they would say oh my God like
Marvel's just ripping off Mystique now
they're just trying to find a way to
throw Mystique in there by giving her a
different name and making her a
different gender and making her like a
totally different person entirely
whatever
um I don't know I'm kind of on the fence
about
that yeah I don't know I mean I'm if
Marvel made a runaways or Young Avengers
film it wouldn't draw me to the theaters
I'll say
that
uh let's
see how did Magneto kill Apocalypse in
Age of Apocalypse he literally tore him
in half like he manipulated the iron in
his blood and just ripped him in half
that's quite literally what
happened uh let's
see scroll back up most underrated
villain that's a good
[Music]
one well since this is Comics explain
let's talk about both DC and
Marvel
huh
underrated villain in Marvel
Comics
o i mean there's all kinds of cool
villains
though see that's the problem Marvel
Marvel gives a lot of their okay I think
one of the most underwriter villains is
the Mad thinker the Mad thinker in
Marvel Comics doesn't get a whole lot of
recognition like whenever he appears
it's always for a short amount of time
and he's usually always tied into a
silly storyline like he was part of
Civil War but the Mad fingers role in
Civil War was to go to conflict between
like the forces of Iron Man and the
forces of Captain America and the
Fantastic Four because he was like with
them out of the way I can take over the
world and that was stupid and so I was
like okay that's kind of a dumb thing to
do with the Mad thinker um the Puppet
Master is very similar too I think the
Puppet Master is a little underrated his
most significant role that I recall is
either Civil War or during Deadpool
kills of Marvel Universe when he has um
uh yeah when Deadpool makes him make
like different models of characters and
then they start killing each other off
or I guess he has them killing killing
themselves off I mean that's that's kind
of the thing that that really
like I guess it really matters with a
puppet master but nonetheless
um
uh how do I think X-Men apocalypse is
going to go down
um I think X1 apocalypse is simply going
to be the introduction of Apocalypse I
mean see I think a lot of people looked
at X the idea of X-Men apocalypse and
they said oh Agee of Apocalypse this is
going to be Age of Apocalypse no no no
no no it's not going to be Age of
Apocalypse it's going to be the
introduction of Apocalypse um I think
this is going to be a story where the
X-Men just can't win and because that's
the way it was in the comics the X-Men
never beat apocalypse they never
defeated apocalypse like apocalypse died
only one time I think over the course of
his entire continuity and that was when
he was taken away by the
celestials and that was that was way
after that that was oh
God that was long at that was actually
that wasn't that long ago that was about
10 years ago I think
no seven years ago that came after
during the whole um after the whole
Messiah complex and all that stuff that
was his own story line um when he when
he came back and uh well no it was yeah
yeah that was I mean I guess he kind of
died during the 12 when he was merged
with
Cyclops but I mean he was still like
Marvel was like no he's still alive but
of course apocalypse is alive and well
now the due to the whole axis thing like
he's him his whole self now but um how
do we get on that oh yeah yeah yeah so
I'm terrible about going out on tangents
um so yeah I think that that in the in
the comic books the X-Men never
succeeded in defeating apocalypse they
just held apocalypse off as best they
could until apocalypse was like okay
fine I give up and then he left or they
just beat up up the four horsemen and
then that would be
it with X-Men apocalypse I think it's
going to
be it's healthy for you though so I got
to drink it but um I think with X-Men
apocalypse it's going to be a story
whereby apocalypse shows up and he's
like basically look like let's fight and
they're going to fight apocalypse he's
going to beat the ever loving [__] out
of him and that's going to be it and
they're going to be like okay we got to
fall back and like we'll continue this
in the next few
movies I don't know at least I'm hoping
that's how it's going to be
done
uh what Spidey villain would you want to
see in a film I am rooting for
chameleon what's Spider-Man villain I
mean Spider-Man has a pretty big Rogues
Gallery
um I think chameleon would be a cool
character chameleon would change up the
landscape in a lot of ways for the
Spider-Man conflicts because imagine if
you had
chameleon youve got a guy they can shape
shift basically or they can take on
forms of other people um he'd be almost
impossible for Spider-Man to catch the
only way Spider-Man would really be able
to find him at least if they do it the
way I would want him to do it um would
be like when chameleon was getting ready
to attack him and then his Spider Sense
would go off you know either that or
just do like like Venom no not really
Venom do Carnage that would be a good
one is Carnage make a Spider-Man film
rate R and give us Cletus Cassidy who
will just start running around and
killing people like give us Maximum
Carnage that would be cool
um what do I think about DC making
Aquaman like Neymar I don't think
Marvel's making Aquaman like I don't
think DC is making Aquaman to be like
Neymar I
mean I don't think so at all I think
that
um they're introducing a important
character from the DC continuity as they
should be doing and he's going to unite
the Justice League I mean I don't think
they're building him up to be like
Neymar I mean
now
uh the producer of the X-Men film says
he would love to do a crossover film
with the Avengers how do you think an
Avengers versus X-Men film would go
down I would only see an Avengers versus
X-Men film if it was being made by the
Marvel Cinematic Universe by Marvel
Studios if Fox had a hand in it then it
would just be
like Avengers versus X-men watch this
film become a catastrophe is what it
would be it would be absolutely
pitiful
um do I think Captain America's Civil
War will be following the original Civil
War storyline or not if not any ideas on
what they might do um I do not think
that it's going to follow the original
Civil War storyline and I have mentioned
this like countless times I I to the to
my dying day until the movie comes out I
will repeat this phrase and if it comes
out and it's different then I will say
okay fine guys I was wrong I do not
think Captain America 3 Civil War is
going to follow the original comic book
storyline and the reason why is because
the original Civil War was just too big
the original Civil War was huge here's
the thing you guys got to remember with
the original Civil War storyline
regardless of what Benny might say or
Sal might say or something like that to
me it was just as much a political piece
as it was let's just make everybody
fight like there it split the entire
superhuman Community down the middle all
the way down to characters like
Tigra I mean hero For Hire I mean you
had you had the community split all the
way down the middle people picking sides
that's what made Civil War such a huge
conflict was superheroes fighting
superheroes it's one of the things that
made it so popular but for me it also
had all the political things that went
along with it Captain America too
established the politics of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's a lot more
going on than the the chitauri invading
New York City like there's this huge
undercurrent of very serious things
taking place the political Spectrum the
you know fear you know eliminate
oppression you know which one do you
value most Freedom versus security so on
and so forth the Captain America 2
solidified all that now what we need are
more superheroes to broaden the base of
super heroes in the Marvel continuity
and even super villains so that this
story can be done in a way so that we
can have this great big conflict between
all these different characters that's my
thought anyway um but again I think that
I think that's how it needs to be done
but again I don't think it's going to
follow the actual comic book story
because the comic book story is just way
too big I mean you're talking about a
series expanded the course of a year
over a 100 issues and to this day is
probably the most successful series that
Marvel's ever done in the history of
Marvel Comics obviously you can't do
something like that in a full movie at
least at least I think so anyway so I I
didn't mean for that to come off
condescending I'm sorry if it
didn't
um uh
did okay am I looking for the next
seasons of The
Flash am I looking forward to the next
seasons of The Flash I'm not
sure I'm not sure what you
mean
uh
where do I think the MCU will go after
Thanos what threat could possibly come
next I don't know I
mean that's kind of the
problem that's kind of the big
thing the Marvel Cinematic Universe
right now is leading up to Infinity
Gauntlet I mean that's what it's leading
up
to Thanos has been on a crusade
Gathering the infinity gems exactly what
he's been doing right now there are no
Infinity gyms that are located in a
place where Thanos could not get to them
at least if Thanos in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is the same Thanos
from the comics that is to say with his
power and his intellect um we know that
the power gym is housed on xandar Thanos
can break into that place smash it to
pieces and take it we know that um the
reality gy was on uh was with a
collector where it is right now I don't
know and that may be I don't know I
don't think we I don't think we find out
where where that one went to I think in
Thor of the Dark World The Ether was
taken to the
collector and then we never found out
what happened after that not to my
knowledge anyway so
um I think that um that you know all the
all the gyms are going to be in a place
where Thanos can simply just grab them
attain them and then take them and do
what he wants with them
um I mean after Infinity Gauntlet where
do you go I mean what do you do I mean
there's some really really big stories
Civil War of course I think will
probably be the next big thing but after
that like God I don't
[Laughter]
know do I think the DC Cinematic
Universe can ever catch up to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe of course it just
depends on what characters they want to
do it depends on what they want to uh
want what they want to do with their
characters I mean how big are they going
to make them how huge are they going to
you know what are they going to do with
them I mean are they going to combine
things Under One Roof see that's the
problem that the DC Cinematic Universe
has in comparison to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which I don't like to
compare the two because they're two
totally sep separate universes and
things are doing different they're doing
different things with them but
um I think that the problem with the DC
Universe is they're not consolidating
all of it Under One Roof like you had
Chris R Nolan's Batman and then you had
Zack Snider Superman and then you have
this Batman versus Superman and then you
have um a Supergirl who's going to get
her own thing but she's not going to
cross over with flash or uh Arrow as far
as I understand DC may or may not reboot
the Green Lantern that's the problem I
don't think they have like a cohesive
plan like Gotham I don't even think is
crossing over with green arrow or or
Flash so I don't I don't know I mean
they don't have any real cohesive
cohesiveness going on there now if they
did that if DC if the executives of DC
came back and Warner Brothers and those
guys and they said hey look we've leased
all of you guys the rights to this we
haven't given them to you like you guys
are borrowing these rights if you guys
don't start combining this into one
combined Universe like like we're taking
it all away um and they they forced the
televisor and I guess the the writers to
bring them all into one cohesive
Universe it would easily rival the
Marvel Cinematic Universe if not maybe
exceed the Marvel Cinematic Universe
because DC characters I think in a lot
of ways are a lot more well-known I mean
for example like DC you got Batman
Superman Wonder Woman the flash green
arrow not really green arrow uh Green
Lantern Aquaman like you've got the
original like you got maybe not the
original but you got the Justice League
all right what'll compose the Justice
League all right you've got villains
like Sinestro you got villains like The
Joker you've got um Lex Luther probably
one of the most well-known villains ever
in the history of comic books you've got
um I guess who else Solomon Grundy I
mean you've got different villains from
DC Comics that off the top of my head I
can tell you you know I know who these
I've heard of these villains I know who
they are when it comes to Marvel Comics
you've got like Magneto you've got um
Captain America you've got Spider-Man
you've got you know but while each of
these characters has her own notable
villains I think that DC's villain
character relationship is a lot more
well well known than Marvel Comics is
but I don't know I think it all just
depends thoughts on super boy super boy
punched reality and broke it enough
said
uh all right what do you think of the
Shazam film being separated from the
Justice League films they won't cross
over until after what they have
planned I think it's a smart move um I
think that if they came along and they
said okay um we're going to have Shazam
Captain Marvel as I remember him all
right before they changeed the name
um if they have Shazam like people are
showing up like did this just this just
start we've been going for about half an
hour guys so we've got about another I
don't know maybe another hour or so I'm
not sure how long I'll make this last
but
um if they
h if they come back and and they were to
give us Shazam almost immediately after
the Superman film people would say okay
look like what is going on here like who
the hell is this Shazam guy um because a
lot of the public mainstreams not going
to be able to differentiate the two and
even then that was the basis for uh the
original DC lawsuit against the creators
of uh of Captain Marvel I don't remember
what their name is but the original
lawsuit was that the characters are too
similar while Billy Batson gets his
powers from shouting Shazam nonetheless
he has the attributes of Superman and so
people were getting kind of confused
uh let's see I don't know why this guy's
typing in all
caps you got to stop typing in all caps
I'm just going to kick you out of the
chat
uh let's
see um I answer the question about
Infinity Wars um at the beginning of the
video DC has an annoying fan base I
don't think DC has an annoying fan base
DC has a fan base that's just as rabid
as you
guys see that's the funny thing
like and let's let's all right real talk
for a second guys like let's be real for
a
second I
knew that changing from Marvel explained
to Comics explained was going to get me
a lot of [__] like I knew a lot of
people were just going to be like no no
you can't do DC on this channel Rob I
know it's your YouTube channel Rob I
know you're the one that makes the C
but you can't do this all right I know
that like I I knew it was going to give
me a whole bunch of flack but at the end
of the day like I have total control
over what I do on this YouTube channel
there's never an instance when I don't
decide what happens like at no point I'm
ever am I ever out of control and so you
know for me like seeing just how rabid a
lot of the Marvel fans were on here like
the hardcore Marvel Comics fans like I
knew right off the bat that people were
just going to flip their [__] I knew
right off the bat they were going to
lose it but um but no I mean it's it's
there's nothing wrong with DC Comics
guys like DC Comics is just as awesome
as as anything else I mean some of the
DC stories like Batman Court of owls is
[__] amazing like I don't know if you
guys have read Batman Court of owls it's
freaking fantastic all right Superman
red Sun is one of the coolest stories
that I've ever read it came out it was
you know 2003 it was written by Mark
Miller and it was awesome but I mean it
was it was awesome I think you know it
was it was crazy me but I don't know I
don't it's
uh it was funny
uh oh man a May movie confirmed
Adventure Quest
explained oh man most DC fans are also
really Marvel and vice
versa yeah see to me I don't I don't see
anything I mean I don't you know I don't
I don't think it's like you
know uh Court of vs will get finished
probably in the next couple weeks um I
don't think I don't know see this is
something I never understood you know
about about people who are like I'm a
fan of Marvel Comics like I don't read
DC like why not you're missing out on
some pretty badass
stories why not so I I don't know that's
that's just that's the one thing that
cracked me up is is I knew that when I
began to switch things over I knew that
when I switched from Marvel explain to
Comics explain that people were going to
start leaving in droves I knew that
views were going to start going down on
my videos but that ultimately like it's
all part of a bigger picture and the
bigger picture here is that I'm moving
forward with with this YouTube channel
it's moving into bigger and better
things and there were some who are going
to stay and some who are not but what
this has shown me with this whole
transition has shown me is to show me
the people who support me as a YouTuber
and the people who don't and the ones
who don't were the ones who were lambing
me on the comics telling me I'm dropping
off I don't know what I'm doing and so
on and so forth the ones who support me
as a YouTuber were like I will watch
watch your [__] whatever you put up I
don't care what it is you know and
that's a very warming experience to have
so um The Joker is the greatest villain
ever okay here's why the Joker is such a
great villain all right let's let's get
into some some philosophy here all right
well let's let's do some philosophizing
on this on this YouTube on this uh this
live stream all right one of the biggest
reasons why the Joker was such a
massively awesome character is not
because of his jokes or the stunts that
he pulls they're funny don't get me
wrong the Joker funny as hell all right
I liked the Joker because the Joker is
what we could be if we weren't
limited like that The Joker Is people
existing or is a man existing with no
limitations no societal structures on
him he can do whatever he wants he can
be whatever he wants it doesn't matter
to him like he doesn't abide by the law
he has 100% total freedom like he is
free to his Madness and his mad Madness
lets him do whatever he wants to do the
Joker is a reflection of in truth what I
would consider to be okay so if we're
gonna if we're going to do if we're
going to do this philosophy thing let's
go balls of the
wall in philosophy there is a
concept called a state of nature all
right and we'll get back to the
questions here in a second in philosophy
there's a concept called a state of
nature the state of nature is what
society would be like if there were no
ordered government basically like chaos
all right different philosophers have
different takes uh Jean Jac Russo for
example argued that a state of nature
would be like the Eloy from The Time
Machine if you ever read that HG Wells
novel all
right these are are different aspects
and different concepts that different
different philosophers hold all right
the Joker to me is a depiction or is a
reflection of um oh God what was his
name um Thomas Hobs in a state of nature
where Thomas hob said that life is short
brutish and cruel and that basically you
have to do whatever you need to do in
order to to make it and that if if you
simply can't hack it on your own then
that's your problem and so I'm not
smoking a
remote uh why are you putting hint on
explain that's kind of [__] up but um
but no The Joker is a society or is a
reflection of what society would be like
if people weren't Bound by rules if
people had the freedom to do whatever it
is they wanted to do they would just
kind of devolve into total chaos and
Anarchy because they wouldn't know what
to do they would they'd have no idea
where to go from there you guys are
creeping me out with that hint I
explained [__] but but
um yeah we'll do Image Comics at some
point along the
line uh who was the new Joker for the
movies if you're talking about suicide
squad that is Jared Leto I think who was
in um um oh God what was what was that
movie uh rec room for a dream which was
a fantastic movie if you guys haven't
seen it yet
um the Fantastic 4 and Wolverine should
go to Marvel but the rest of the X-Men
should stay with Fox I I would not be
adverse to that
except for Gambit I want to see Gambit
in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe um spawn was a great character
from back in the day like he was awesome
favorite non-marvel uh DC Comic graphic
novel like a graphic novel that's not
based on Marvel or DC that's like an
independent graphic novel um I mean are
we talking
about
like I mean I'm not sure like image or
I'm not I'm not sure what you
mean um I want to see the Joker take the
Joker's daughter go all Batman and Robin
take the fight to
Batman on that front be a symbol of
death and Insanity like how Batman is a
symbol of fear for the
criminals
um with the Apocalypse movies coming our
way how extensive do you see uh See it
going I.E possibilities for Horsemen and
the picking choosing of them Mr Sinister
cable Etc are you talking about in the
films um how is a apocalypse going to
pick his four horsemen well here's the
deal when apocalypse picks his four
horsemen he picks them based on How
likely they are to be able to be
effective I mean How likely can they
hold their own keep in mind apocalypse
philosophy is survival of the fittest if
a person can survive almost unbeatable
odds then apocalypse will choose them to
be a Horseman or sometimes it's just a
matter of convenience for example the
original Four Horsemen one of them was a
Morlock the other one was a vet who had
survived um after he landed on a grenade
which I guess showed great courage or
something like that um another one was
oh God I think I think it was pestilence
who was the girl who could kill things
by touching it um or wither them away
like age them basically U but it's weird
like apocalypse shows up in her bedroom
and is like hey look like you want to be
a Horseman I can give you a place you
know in society and she she's like cool
yeah let's do it which is kind of
strange when you think about it but
nonetheless um no I think that that we
won't really see cable or anything like
that
um this is the problem with Fox
launching just launching an Apocalypse
movie is I mean how do you lead up to it
I mean there's no lead up to this the
the only leadup to this was like a 30
second trailer that we saw at the end of
X-Men Days of Future Past that was it I
mean I have no idea where they're going
to go from here I have no idea how
they're going to introduce the Four
Horseman I mean how would you do I guess
in the first 15 minutes he just rounds
them all up gives them Powers done and
done I mean what what why would I care
about the four horsemen what makes them
what makes them compelling and that's
the difference see the four hor men and
the comics were cool because to you they
weren't just cannon fodder you were just
like oh hey like I really want to see
like these four horsemen and the X-Men
Fight it'd be really awesome to see that
happen but if I can't identify with them
if I don't know anything about them and
as far as I know they were just randomly
picked off the street then I don't care
if they live or die and it takes away
the entire basis behind why the four
horsemen matter in the first
place uh let's
see
uh do I think they will take any of the
characters that dies in The X X movies
to become Horsemen I don't think so I
think they'll probably make wolver rain
a Horsemen maybe but I think that'll be
about be about the extension of it
because keep in mind days of feature
pass wiped out everything after X-Men 2
I think it wiped out um X-Men 3 it wiped
out uh Wolverine Origins wiped out all
that stuff like all that's
[Laughter]
gone oh God the max yes the max was
awesome back in the day and the cartoon
show was even amazing it was even more
amazing than that um Amadeus
Cho you want me to do a video on Amadeus
Cho uh X-Men Days of Future Past was not
terrible that was a great
movie is there going to be New Gods
explained or Green Lantern core
explained yes we're going to explain the
Green Lantern core and we're going to do
the new Gods like that's going to be
something we're we're really really
going to have to do because with
convergence like we have to understand
that stuff and and this is this is the
thing that we need to do like I really
want to get back into doing lead UPS so
it's like hey like this leads up to
which we're going to start that with
Secret Wars we're going to be like hey
um like here's Secret Wars like here's
the secret Wars leadup that's what the
video is going to be coming out later on
today that's what that one's going to be
about it's going to be about the leadup
to Secret Wars like here's the stories
that we know Marvel's doing here's how
they're going to be based on here's
what's going to happen with them years
of Future Past is's going to be a
continuation after the events of Days of
Future Past um the area I think it's
called The Regency is going to be based
on Spider-Man one more day and
Spider-Man Annual number 21 the story
itself is going to Beall renew your
vowes but it's basically going to
nullify one more day it's going to tell
us what life would be like if Peter
Parker and Mary Jane Watson hadn't
gotten divorced you know that's the kind
of thing we're going to see with a lot
of those stories and so we got to do
lead-ups to that what was Spider-Man one
more day why does Spider-Man one more
day matter why did Spider-Man fans hate
it why was it that when Spider-Man one
more day came out trinsky was like yeah
I wrote it but you know like just
pretended I
didn't you know why is it why why did
that kind of thing happen you know why
why are things like that so
um any recommended New 52 trades post
Throne of Atlantis um I'd say the entire
current run of Batman is amazing I would
say if you haven't already start with
Batman zeroy year and just read forward
and that's gonna that's it's gonna
freaking blow your
mind
uh
why does Marvel oh
crap
uh let's
see oh crap
oops I accidentally left the uh left the
thing okay um screw go who do you think
the model Cinematic Universe Peter
Quill's father is oh god um the coffee
is coffee's right here um am I going to
delete the DC explain Channel actually
if you go to the DC explain Channel
right now there's no videos on there and
the reason there's no videos is because
they're all
unlisted I might turn DC explain into
like a gaming channel like just play
video games on there I don't know upload
like some Minecraft or something I have
no idea if any of you guys like if any
of you guys play Minecraft send me an
email like with Minecraft in the title
and and work together and play some
Minecraft because I think it'd be fun to
like play Minecraft with you guys and
just upload the videos to DC explained
like that'd be cool and may be kind of
weird calling a DC explained and playing
Minecraft but whatever Channel names
don't really matter in the URL it's like
the main theme of the channel I think
it's really the only thing that matters
but nonetheless so um what flavor am I
vaping I am
vaping uh peach Melba by the Vapor Chef
and it is
amazing it is so good um oh God you guys
really seem to like the idea of
Minecraft um
Minecraft Minecraft yeah send me an
email if you guys want to play some
Minecraft no I don't like doing Trolling
Videos
um let's see Gary's
Mod now everybody's just like posting
titles of
games I like how you guys do that I like
how I'm like like hey guys like do what
do you guys think about this idea like
you know what do you guys think about
Minecraft and you guys are just like
Minecraft Minecraft Minecraft and it's
just like all these things delve out and
then people start posting like all these
crazy names and stuff like that you guys
crack me up so um all right why does
oops let's scroll back up why does
Marvel characters ever fear Extinction
on the Earth being captured since they
have Franklin Richards who can fix
everything
okay Marvel made a mistake with Franklin
Richards and I think Marvel recognized
this characters like mad Jim Jaspers
were different all right mad Jim Jaspers
Marvel introd UC his character and
killed him off in a single continuity
all right it was a crooked World
storyline Marvel introduced his
character they said okay here's a guy
that can who reality he's really
dangerous so on and so forth we had Roma
the we had saturnine the universal
magistri we had Merlin the the
omniversal guardian we had all these
different things going on all right when
they killed off mad Jim jasp that was it
there was no more guy who could War
reality it was done and done and then
Marvel continued on with the idea of
Franklin Richards because again Franklin
Richards came long before mad Jim Jasper
he came about I don't know about 18
years or something like that no about 12
years before mad Jim Jasper something
like that maybe a little bit a little
bit more than that but um less than 20
years before MIM Jasper's anyway and
Marvel built on the idea that Franklin
Richards could warp reality but then all
of a sudden fans were asking the
question if Franklin richers can warp
reality then why is there why are there
any conflicts whatsoever in the Marvel
Universe why doesn't he just like Snap
his fingers and and uh postpone AVG
wants to restart my computer that ain't
happening but um but you know why there
any conflicts whatsoever why doesn't
Frank Richard just fix everything and so
they basically wrote him into the
background to where they never utilize
it but the problem is that that
Pandora's Box has been opened and so any
time there's a conflict like
Annihilation and Nova Richard Ryder
comes back during Civil War and he says
hey look guys I know you're fighting
here on the planet with the Civil War
thing but Annihilation is going on out
here and anilist is killing everybody
and you should really be worried about
this people are like why doesn't
Franklin Richards just wipe out anilist
just kill off anilist and all his force
is done and done and that that's the
problem that Marvel has and that's one
of the big reasons why Franklin Richards
is now dead in the Marvel
continuity they killed
him oh man who do I think the Marvel
Cinematic universe's Peter Quill's
father is uh you know what Leo gulage is
right Peter Quill's father is CM Punk we
all know that let us let it go forward
from here CM Punk that is Frank
Richard's
father just uh make memes and stuff like
that's what you guys should do you guys
should make memes about CM Punk being
Franklin Richard's father and then send
it off to CM Punk it's like that'd be
awesome
um once Marvel Cinematic Universe is
finished with Civil War and The Infinity
Gauntlet Saga where do you think they'll
go what story arc series Saga Etc I
don't know
um I think that
H I already did a video on Richard Ryder
I think that
with post Infinity gaet post Civil
War I don't
know and this is why I think Marvel kind
of wrote themselves into a corner
um questions are coming in while I'm
trying to answer this
question
um I think that with battle world and
Marvel consolidating all the realities
down into into one giant location that
there really isn't the opportunity for
them to make more realities now they
will I mean they'll say okay yeah
there's battle world but then there's
like realities that escaped the
incursions and that's how those
realities are going to grow and form and
so on and so forth um I think
that I don't know
see Marvel's getting rid of all these
alternate realities I mean they're
getting rid of all these old stories
basically I mean all that stuff's going
away so I don't [__] I don't
know I don't know see I think that's a
big mistake by Marvel but
uh original sin would be a good one uh
we don't know how Franklin Richards died
it's it's in uh New Avengers issue
number uh
God it's in New Avengers issue number 28
whatever the most recent one is that
came out I think it's 28
um uh Reed Richards is talking about all
the sacrifices they've made in order to
to try to end the incursions and one of
the things that he had done was use his
son Franklin Richards I guess his
reality warping powers or something like
that but Franklin Richards died in the
process that's really all we know like
like all we saw was that he's holding
Franklin Richards in his arms Franklin
Richards looks like he's unconscious and
Reed Richards says like there's so much
that's been like we've lost so much
already and that's it
so
uh Fury told Thor that he had a sister
no way
okay tell me tell me what you guys think
about what you guys think read Richards
I'm sorry what Nick Fury said to Thor
like give me your your suggestions give
me your speculations because I want to
read those I want to see what's
up yeah Franklin Richards is a son of
Reed Richards he has the ability to warp
reality Jason Todd explained yes we'll
do
him uh is a Punisher ever getting a
movie um I don't think Punisher will
ever get like a movie per se I think
they're just going to like throw him
into the movies I think they're just
going to say like because I mean they've
introduced him already and well not
really not directly but they pretty much
told us in Captain America the Winter
Soldier like there's two instances where
a Pinsky truck uh crashes and more or
less like saves Captain America's ass
and um what what they said during like
the director cut director credits or
something like that is like that's the
Punisher that's Frank Castle that did
that and so they were like Frank Castle
basically saved Captain America twice
and Captain America the Winter Soldier
and so um it looks to me like they're
going to bring him into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I'm pretty sure
they've confirmed
that I want to sleep in the chat nope
you can always leave though
um n you're to Thor your second movie
sucked you are no longer
worthy that Theon Smith guy your second
movie sucked you are no longer worthy
um I would maybe kind of believe that uh
no Franklin Richards is way below the
one above all the one above all created
the
entire like concept of the Marvel
Cinematic or the Marvel Universe like
the Marvel Multiverse he created all
that stuff
no uh I think a Punisher movie would be
good if they made it good like Punisher
war zone was terrible but it was based
on the series Punisher war zone like it
sucked um they need to give Punisher his
own TV show and on Netflix and they need
to base it off of Punisher MAX let me
tell you something guys for those of you
guys who are not familiar with Punisher
if you want to know where to start with
a Punisher see this is why I haven't
made a Punisher where to start video
because what this here's here's what the
Punisher where to start video would be
like what's going on guys this is Rob
and welcome to where to start a weekly
series y okay go read Punisher MAX
thanks for watching guys yall have a
good one peace that'd be the
video that'd be it like Punisher MAX is
the only thing that matters you could
consider Punisher war journals like the
uh you know but those were okay but
Punisher MAX is really where it's at
that's where you get like the really
good like hardcore Punisher stuff at is
in Punisher MAX um and Thomas Janes
should come back as a Punisher hell yeah
like who else is going to play The
Punisher
effectively I mean I guess you could
have like Vinnie Jones that like he'd be
a terrible
Punisher
Nick Fury told Thor he is a clone not
the real Odin son that would be such a
kick in the balls holy [__] or if he's
not the son of Thor son of
Odin oh
God I mean see that's something that's
always driven me crazy is what in the
hell was it that was
said you got a big
booty okay okay let's Analyze This gu
let's let's talk about this all
right let's think back on the continuity
of Thor all right let's think back on
the history of Thor in in Marvel
Comics we know that Thor was thrown into
the body of a man named Donald
Blake we know that this was done by Odin
in order to Humble
Thor we know that once Donald Blake
became aware of this that he would
basically operate he was he was like the
Superman Clark hint relationship all
right when he wasn't Thor he was Donald
Blake when he wasn't Donald Blake he was
Thor um he met Jane Foster yada y
y I mean he died during
Ragnarok he came back due to
[Music]
the God I don't know see that see that I
think is the key I think Ragnarok is the
key
maybe maybe Odin told or maybe uh Nick
Fury told him Ragnarok never ended
the Ragnarok is still
going would not would that not be a kick
in the balls if they came back and said
that like raknarok never ended because
remember guys like the the whole basis
of Thor Ragnarok was
that with Thor Ragnarok I'm sorry with
the Ragnarok process Ragnarok was
basically like the end of times for Thor
or the Thor the Asgard into the whole
universe but the way this happened is
you had the ones who sit above in Shadow
all right the ones who sit above in
Shadow's identities weren't really given
to us all we knew was that the Asgardian
Universe at some point along the line
had come into existence all right the
ones who stood above in Shadow was
somewhere in existence now as a result
of basically what happened is the
Asgardian Universe would come to an end
it would reach this Armageddon the
Armageddon was called Ragnarok when this
happened the ones who sit above in
Shadow would feed on the energy of the
dead and then the entire process would
start over again the universe would be
created that's how the ones who sit
above in Shadow sustain themselves and
so every like all the time it was
constantly repeating itself over and
over and over and over again and the uh
the ASG Guardians were stuck in like
this endless cycle of living and dying
think of it like um like a edge of the
edge of tomorrow if you guys have seen
that yet that was basically how things
happened every time Tom Cruz died that
was Ragnarok for the Asgard
all right once Thor realized this
realized what was going on he supposedly
destroyed the ones who sit above in
Shadow by by destroying the tree oh
God oh
God I figured it
out I figured out what Nick Fury said to
Thor oh my God I just figured it
out oh oh
man okay that's
awesome where's the troll
at
uh oh
yeah who's that guy oh yeah let's uh
yeah that guy's
banned okay that joean Nissan guy yeah I
banned that guy um
okay oh God I can't believe I just
figured that
out oh man God damn
Thor [__]
Thor okay so let's scroll back up and uh
get into questions get back into the
questions
again okay
um I'm scrolling back up to the
questions we SP so long going on
rants why does Fox have the rights to
the Scrolls King Galactus and Silver
Surfer while Black Panther and the
Inhumans also first appeared in
Fantastic 4 Comics um that is a good
question they're not Fantastic 4
properties just because they appeared in
the Fantastic 4 doesn't mean they're
they're Fantastic 4 properties um
with Spider-Man for example Spider-Man
and his Rogues Gallery are Spider-Man
properties because they are are Rogues
or they're villains that that are tied
directly into Spider-Man they are the
main foes of Spider-Man um in truth it's
just however Marvel wants it to be but
the other thing to also keep in mind is
that Marvel also had Thor and Marvel
kept the rights to Thor and the Inhumans
entire Origins and a lot of their
stories were told in backup features for
the Thor comics and so they were
featured in more than just the uh just
the Fantastic th
but uh good morning real
skills uh let's see Rob's Theory
explained I can't believe I figured that
out oh man Galactus is not a fox
property um what I have a feeling of is
that Marvel is that the the characters
themselves become the properties of a
group if their Origins are explained in
those properties but the origins of the
Inhumans were explained in the in th and
the backup features for Thor so will I
ever cover the Blue Beetle uh yeah at
some point I don't know why
not it couldn't
hurt uh SI is pregnant that would that
would be hilarious like if Nick Fury
like whispered to Thor like you are not
the father or like you are the father
that'd be some [__] wouldn't it that's
like a Mor poish episode
like somebody needs to I'm going to do
that I'm I'm going to do that like I'm
gonna open Photoshop right now and we're
we're going to work on that for the next
for the next second or two like we're
going to take Mor poic's head and we're
going to superimpose it onto
on why am I doing this all right
um Thor original sin
unworthy what did thou
say h where is it where did what was it
that Nick Fury whispered to
him oh man
that's what it needs to say is like oh
here it is here it is all it took was a
whisper you are the
father that needs to happen that so
needs to happen Mory
Fury
um all right Rob which of your favorite
X-Men cartoon series '90s Evolution or
Wolverine and the X-Men oh X-Men the
Animated Series hands down I
mean oh they have to pick between
evolution or wolver the Xmen definitely
X-Men evolution X-Men evolution was was
better of the two but X-Men the Animated
Series is better than all than the other
two like both of those
so
uh would you eat iron brand for
breakfast Honey Bunches of
HX uh gold man yes we'll have to get
back together at some point along the
line and do that but like the next day
was not the best
time you going have to give me a little
time cuz that was kind of a lengthy
interview
um does anybody like or have any
interest in Young Justice not
me don't hate me but I actually like the
'90s comics everyone always talks about
the bad ones but there were some good
yeah there were some great '90s Comics
X-Men 91 came out 1991 the highest
selling comic of all time that was a
great
comic
going to
play do I think do I think Nick Fury is
going to play any part in the new secret
oh Nick Fury as The Watcher ah
definitely they have to bring him back
like they have to show him as the
Watcher I don't know why they
wouldn't
uh it was all
Deadpool Rob would you want Marvel to
give Sony a big middle finger and make a
Jessica Drew Spider Girl movie or do you
think it would just sour a good
relationship I mean they couldn't they
can't do spider girl she's part of the
spider I mean I I'm not really sure what
would happen if they did I imagine
they'd be subjected to like lawsuits or
maybe Sony would have an injunction
filed against them so they couldn't make
the film I don't know what would happen
or they would just say like give us all
the money for the film because those are
properties that don't belong to you I'm
not really sure but um I I don't know I
mean it'd be kind of funny though
Guardians of the Galaxy 2 is rumored to
be about Annihilation would you do
Annihilation and Conquest
um I don't know
know at some point along the line
maybe what kind of music do I listen to
oh I like everything like I listen to
Sting I listen to um like corn like my
my favorite album from corn was um
Follow the Leader no no that's not right
issues was my favorite album from corn
um electronic music Progressive house
stuff like that like I like the
progressive house sound like the Housey
trance sound that's my favorite kind of
music
uh Rob can you help us make sense of
what's to come of the Spider-Man movies
is The Amazing Spider-Man 3 canceled now
are they recasting Spider-Man in the MCU
will either be tied together Canon wise
what's coming all
right so let's answer that question
because that's a pretty good question to
ask
um oh my vaporizer going off over there
um with a Spider-Man film uh what
Marvel's basically saying here is that
Kevin figy and Amy Pascal are basically
going to help Sony reboot their
Spider-Man franchise as far as I
understand they're going to reboot it
again only this time Marvel's going to
have a hand Marvel's basically going to
fix their problem that's pretty much
what happened Sony was like okay let's
do like the original Spider-Man they had
San Ry and that went on for like three
movies and the third one was absolute
garbage the second one was kind of like
me and the first one was the best of
that three and then they came back and
said okay let's reboot it again and the
whole reason why they had to reboot it
is because they didn't have any ideas
and two they had to keep making movies
otherwise Sony gets the rights or Marvel
gets the rides back and so they rebooted
Amazing Spider-Man or rebooted The
Amazing Spider-Man series with Amazing
Spider-Man with Andrew Garfield right
with Andrew Garfield coming back they
gave us one which is pretty good they
gave us two which was garbage and then
they have to go back and do it again and
so because their ship is basically
sinking at a rapid Pace when it comes to
Spider-Man people are losing faith in
Sony's ability to make good Spider-Man f
films they reached out to Marvel and
they were like okay guys like help us
make this good film and so Marvel said
okay we'll do that but you have to let
us have Spider-Man and the Civil War
continuity like that's the only thing we
ask and so they were like okay cool you
guys get that because here's what's
going to happen with Spider-Man being in
Civil War it's going to catapult that
film like before people were like okay
cool Captain America civil war Civil War
was like the biggest story Marvel's had
in the history of Marvel Comics like
that's going to be a really really good
movie and then people like holy [__]
[__] [__] Spider-Man's going to be in
this oh my God like we got to get on
that [__] and so as a result like it's
catapulted the movie into like a stupid
amount of popularity and so because of
that Sony is going to be rebooting the
entire Spider-Man franchise as I
understand it the concept of a uh of the
Sinister 6 film I think is still there
but I think they're going to put that on
hold to see how this reboot turns out
but again it really just kind of depends
ultimately though I don't know I mean
I'm fingers crossed it'd be kind of a
dick move but I'm hoping that Kevin fagy
and Amy Pascal are just like huddled
together in a dark room somewhere and
they're like okay let's figure out how
to like [__] Sony over so that they just
have to like give us the rights back to
the
movie let's make this movie as terrible
as
possible who do I think should be cast
for Spider-man in truth I wouldn't mind
having Andrew Garfield back Andrew
Garfield was a great Spider-Man but I
think Donald Glover would be an awesome
Spider-Man if they were were going to
give us Miles Morales which they need to
do they need to change it up all right
they've done Peter Parker for like a
whole bunch of movies all right let's
let's like move forward into the 21st
century step away from the 1960s and say
okay guys like let's jump into this
whole thing of Ultimate Spider-Man let's
just call him Miles Morales comic book
fans aren't going to Care [__] we want
to see Miles Morales in a movie like
we're not going to give a damn and so
they just need to do that like I don't
know why they wouldn't
so uh are you an Anime Watcher my
experience with anime was um um Dragon
Ball
FY that's the extension of my experience
with anime uh Logan
lurman I guess it would work Logan
lurman new Spider-Man movie Carnage
played by Jim Carrey
no let me tell you who would make a
great Carnage all
right and you guys might disagree with
me
here but there's an actor in Hollywood
who would make an amazing
Carnage Tomy Maguire crying was horrible
I live for 30 minutes it was painful to
see uh robs on the Miles Morales train
hell yeah I am like he'd be an awesome
Miles
Morales was it even a coincidence Spide
was allowed to be shared after right
after Pascal announced she was leaving
office I don't I don't know I don't
think she was holding it up to be honest
like I don't think she was keeping that
from happening I think she probably
wanted to see that
happen will I play Arkham Knight I don't
know maybe we'll see what's up
watch Cowboy bbop I've heard cowboy bbop
was really good Kevin spy wouldn't
really play the best
carnage uh Jim Carrey buried it's over 9
thousands uh any thoughts on the flash
though the flash though was amazing
um The Flash though was incredible like
I think that the flash all right see
like rodro Rios was the one they got me
like Steve bashim would be an awesome
Carnage imagine him just like all wiry
and crazy and out there like he'd be a
great cus Cassidy he has the look of an
insane person he has the voice of an
insane person you can play an insane
person pretty
well
um what were we Dean Ambrose Dean
Ambrose would be a terrible
Carnage Carnage isn't like 6 foot 10
like Dean Ambrose is
huge uh how can Franklin die cuz
Franklin cuz future Franklin Richards
wouldn't let it happen since he has his
plan to recreate the Universe I don't
know see that's a
question but see that's why it lends
Credence to me that the future Franklin
Richard that we see is not from the
earth 616
continuity CM Puck for
Carnage Rob is the best
carnage I don't think so I'd be a
terrible
Carnage uh what do you do you think God
questions are coming in what do you
think is going on with the Harrison
going on with Harrison
Wells what do you
mean
uh God the questions are coming in so
fast
uh Terry Cruz is Carnage no not at
all killing Spidey would be a bad idea
why limit your potential l options
potential storytelling options I mean
it's time for Spider-Man to change hands
I
think
uh Terry Crew should have played Luke
Cage I don't know how I would feel about
Terry Crew playing Luke Cage
um Terry
Crew He could I mean he's huge like he's
a massive guy but I don't see him as
being able to play a character that's
serious enough and I think that's one of
the big drawbacks when it comes to the
perception of Terry Cruz when you look
at Terry Cruz for what what he is Terry
Cruz is a fantastic actor but I think
the problem is that he gets typ cast
like he's getting typ cast as like the
non-s serious character like people look
at um The Expendables and they say like
that's Terry Crew they look at white
chicks and they say like that's Terry
Cruz like I think that's the problem
that a lot of people
have Jaden Smith Miles Morales let me
tell you something if they came out with
a Jaden Smith Miles Morales film I would
I would just I'd
protest
I don't think Terry Cruz is too old I
just don't think he's the right fit for
the
character uh yes there is a Deadpool
movie coming out in 2016 I think and as
far as I understand Ryan Reynolds is um
no I don't think Ryan Reynolds will
screw up Deadpool I think that Ryan
Reynolds as far as he said the Deadpool
movie is going to be really really
good Carol Danvers or kakon uh
I do my taxes on my own um I think I use
that Turbo Tax I think kamakan is a
great great uh uh Miss
Marvel I don't think she's terrible at
all Michael ji white for Luke Cage I
think Michael JY white would have been a
perfect black panther but they didn't
give it to him and I don't know why I
don't understand why Michael okay here's
the thing I'm an avid fan of Michael J
white I think Michael J white is one of
the most criminally underrated like
action stars in Hollywood I mean granted
like his movies are kind of you know not
necessarily the best that's because he
just doesn't get you know doesn't get
offered really good films like this
would have catapulted him if they had
come out and said like Michael J white
is gonna be playing Black Panther it
would have blown me away because like
Michael J white as I understand it has
like seven different uh has studied
seven different martial arts he's a
legitimate Contender for virtually any
martial arts competition he owns black
belts on all of these different martial
arts he's athletic he's intelligent he's
very capable he's a good actor when he
gets a good role you I mean I think he
could have done awesome but you know
marvel kind of passed him over and I
think I think I think really that's
Marvel's loss passing over um uh Michael
J
white
uh the guy who played R Shack and
Watchman would be oh oh he would he
would be an awesome what was his name it
was a
something I'm going to look that up War
Shack
Watchman
uh God what was his
name um Jackie Earl Haley yeah he would
play an amazing Carnage he'd be a great
Carnage overall like I'd love to see him
as
Carnage uh would I like to see would you
like Stephen AEL as DC Marvel Cinematic
Universe Green Arrow yeah of course I
mean he is as far as the TV shows go but
he definitely needs to be in the movie
like he's that character now like he is
Green Arrow
now oh they so need to do like a 50
Shades of Gray dark pool a Deadpool
story where he's just God that'd be
ridiculous there's nothing greater than
hearing a true fan gush could you spend
about three minutes or so just telling
us how happy you are for Age of Ultron
movie or The Infinity Gauntlet films oh
I'm ridiculously excited for Age of
Ultron
oh my God
like I'm really psyched for Age of
Ultron because it's about time that we
got an Ultron film it's about time we
got a chance to see Ultron just wreak
havoc and just start going absolutely
nuts on uh on on the v in the various
films like that needs to happen now what
I'm really hoping is that this isn't
like a oneandone like it's not a oneoff
like hey guys here's Avengers 2 Age of
Ultron they fight him and then they
destroy him in the same story and he
never comes back I don't want to see
that I want to see future Age of Ultron
films like I want to see him in
different in movies later
on Gary
Bucy uh human target series I never saw
that he played a really good Freddy
Krueger in Nightmare on Elm Street the
movie wasn't written the best but he was
a good Freddy
Krueger Michael J white is Miles Morales
he's a little too old to play Miles
Morales Minecraft I'll be your Irish
friend I think it'd be fun like we could
go in like we can go in and play like uh
like public lobbies like me and Cameron
did that the other the night myself
Cameron and uh I think his I can't
remember what his friend's name was I
think it was Evan um uh anyway we uh the
three of us got together and we were
playing like hideand-seek and that
hideand-seek is amazing in
Minecraft it's so
fun oh
man uh do I have a Marvel unlimited
yes uh the 1990 Flash series was amazing
for Comic property then it wasn't
terrible I remember watching that with
my dad back in the day like it wasn't
the worst ever it was uh it was fun to
see I didn't know who reverse flash was
or any of that stuff which we got to
explain those characters reverse flash
stuff like that like I I need to put in
some more of those characters like we'll
probably do that this week we'll
probably focus a little more on reverse
flash stuff like
that mjw could
be former black panther who's
killed I don't know see as far as I know
there's only been like there's been
tchala he's been the only black panther
aside from his sister and no one else
has played that role so well yeah no no
one else played that role so I don't
know should there be another Daredevil
movie most
definitely oh God Marvel's hitting for a
premier night in Singapore for Age of
Ultron
really uh yeah um yeah Goldman I play um
Minecraft send me an email or well [__]
man you got me on Skype dude just hit me
up on Skype sometime not by now but at
some point
um giving a prediction of future
Avengers cast lineup surprise characters
extensions into Iron Man or into
Ant-Man I don't understand if you're
asking something or if you're telling me
something will Adam Warlock be in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he already
is uh he's already in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
I've indoctrinated my 2-year-old to
watch
Batman do I think we'll get a House of M
movie probably not I mean Fox may do it
just because they want to draw in the
attention but you know I mean I don't
understand how they do it with like a a
little a little kid version of um
Scarlet Witch I mean I don't know how
they do that but
nonetheless uh
Let's
see we good we good Shaq equals
Shazam does Quicksilver and Avengers
mean a new X-Men films are set up for
possible cross into the into into this
Marvel uh no I mean Marvel's already got
Quicks they don't need
him any chance of Legion explained yes
we'll do that when we finish uh when we
uh pick back up with Age of
Apocalypse
when do I think the vision will be added
uh he'll be added during Age of
Ultron what role do I think Howard the
Duck will have in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I don't
know do you think Batman can beat the
Avengers if he had enough prep time yes
easily very
easily
uh Old Man Logan movie I would love to
see an Old Man Logan movie I want to see
an Old Man Logan movie directed by the
um by the uh
maybe the russos or even then like not
really the Russo I mean I guess the
russos could do it it would still be
really good but I'd also like to see one
directed by the um oh
God what were the ones who did
um No Country for Old
Men uh God what were their names we got
to look that
up No Country for Old
Men the Cohen Joel and Ethan Cohen I
want to see
them did we ever do a Rob explained no
we did not do a Rob
explained I'm not sure I want to do a
video explaining
myself I should make a TV series
explaining like Gotham TVs TV series
explain and the Flash explain and so
on uh the Cohen Brothers yep thank you
thank you thank you The Death of
Wolverine I don't know I don't know how
I feel about them doing a movie about
that from the trailers I've seen the
outcome of in DC movies seems a bit more
darker and
grittier how do I get all my information
on Comics I read them a lot of it's just
sitting up here stuff that I've known
for years and years and
years uh War of the
lanterns how do you do an Old Man Logan
without the Hulk that is a good question
how do you do that because they don't
have the rights of the Incredible
Hulk
uh blade reboot Cohen
Brothers Quinton Tarantino would do a
great um Old Man Logan video bring back
sexiness
explained a lot of you guys love my
voice I don't understand
why I mean I guess I could really credit
talk as um as sexy as I possibly could I
don't know how interesting that would be
to you guys but I think that at the end
of the day um you guys would quite enjoy
a sexy
voice let me
[Laughter]
know
um Donald Glover for
Spider-Man with the infinity gaunet
films do you think they'll take place on
Earth or Galactic or actually on a
temple that Thanos built for death will
misto come around the cosmic entities we
don't know um keep in
mind I think that what they're going to
be doing with the infinity Infinity
Gauntlet series to be honest Secret Wars
is I don't
know see Secret Wars 2015 is going to be
rewriting some of the characters or some
of the stories we already know like The
Infinity Gauntlet from Secret Wars is
going to be different from The Infinity
Gauntlet that we saw in 19 whatever it
was all right this is going to be a
story where I think it's going to come
closer to Earth I think that the
Infinity Gauntlet story from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe will tie closer to
the 2015 and Infinity G
story he just
[__] uh Benny style see a lot of
people are like why can't you be more
exciting like I'm I'm just laid back I
mean I'm just chilled like it's just the
way I
am somebody sample that
[__] why are they recasting for
Guardians of the
Galaxy
there are no strings on me in an Ultron
voice all right on one
second there are no strings on
me all right I don't know if that sounds
right I don't know if that sounds like
Ultron but I think it
works all right what's up what do you
think about
[Music]
Thanos being held in The Avengers
animated series oh being in the Avengers
animated series
I don't think Thanos was in The Avengers
animated series is he I need to go check
that
out I enjoy the cool sexiness flowing
through
[Laughter]
you it's that peach
Vape bring back Young Justice
series Star Wars Universe subject to
Marvel's Multiverse incursions
and use your Infinity Gauntlet to
explain videos before the movie
starts Martian
Manhunter okay guys we've been going for
about an hour and a half so we're
gonna we're going to go ahead and uh
we're going to go ahead and get this
down like we're going to go ahead and
bring this to an end
oh man but um yeah so you guys are
cracking me up Rob's voice is amazing
Rob has the best voice ever so on I
never understood why my why people love
my voice so much I don't get that like
okay explain that to me you guys like
all you guys in the chat tell me why you
guys love my voice so
much like help me
understand
like I'm just I'm
looking we will see secret Invasion
explain yes we'll probably do a secret
Invasion at some
point oh
man all right guys
um it's deep Bro
your voice is so
deep yeah I'd like to make this a weekly
thing I think it'd be fun to go back
and Rob you're on
cocaine dark and manly the Deep
raspiness of
it it's so deep and chill the audience
explains Rob's
voice it's got soul
lower frequency range I mean I'm not
even talking that deep right
now like my voice is
is I mean it could be
deeper I mean the the Deep nature of my
voice is normally like a lot lower well
not really a lot lower but like it can
be lower but I don't know I mean like
normally I don't talk this low whenever
I'm whenever I'm doing my videos because
because what ends up happening is
people people get to a point where
they're like all right it's all kind of
blending together I can't understand
what you're saying and so on so I don't
I usually don't like keep it this deep
but I don't know I guess maybe it's up
to you guys but it's it's weird because
usually again like it's it's I don't
know I don't know let me know what you
guys
think oh
man
I mean it's it's weird Rob's beard
explain it's not a beard it's a
goatee I mean it's just like a goatee
give me your deepest
voice oh
God the deepest voice I can give
you um I don't know how deep I can make
my voice but if you guys want to hear a
deep voice you guys need to go check out
a guy called the loyal Patriot that guy
has a deep voice like his vocal cords
are like that big around it's freaking
ridiculous
but but yeah like I think I think we
should make this like a weekly series I
think we should do this every Sunday
where we where I just like live stream
and talk to you guys about stuff I think
it'd be fun
but I don't know what about the Sif
pregnancy
Photoshop
I'll I'll I'll have to do that at some
point I'll try to get that on Twitter
today but um again for those of you guys
who are joining late um I'm going to
have a video coming live here in the
next I don't know about an hour 45
minutes uh supposed to be uploading at
12:00 I think that runs over what we
know about the Marvel Cinematic Universe
or I'm sorry about Secret Wars 2015 um
the stories that we know about the
stories are going to be doing again I
got all that stuff from marvel.com and a
couple interviews around the web from
the people who are writing these stories
but again this is the only this is all
we know about these stories um we don't
know pretty much anything else about any
of the other stories or at least it was
kind of like conjecture so so yeah I
don't know anyway um so let me know uh
yeah so
uh with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this live stream to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later
peace I have the best outro ever